I really know much about it - like no
you know that's a joke that's a joke
that was a joke
please tell me someone's being shot at
that well I guess it's safe to say that
Charlie D'Amelio is a proud
card-carrying belieber very crazy on
Monday the tic-tock star lost her
freaking mind when Justin Bieber slid
into her dance as she was hosting an
insta live it doesn't seem real because
I'm like why why do they know who I'm
just dancing in my room by myself why do
they know who I am Charlie who bTW is
the most followed person on tick-tock
was answering a question when she
spotted the Yummie singers instant
handle pop-up in her feed with a message
that read please check your DM when
you're done you're live thanks her
reaction well just watch for yourself
that's a joke that's a joke that was a
joke please tell me someone's being shot
at that okay I will thank you um oh my
goodness okay oh I need to get my damn
specs ASAP okay who else is dying to
know what the Biebs had to say I think
it's
surreal inquiring minds wanna know
charlie of course she hasn't revealed
what Justin had to say after crashing
her live yet but fans are hopeful
they'll fill us in soon I'm sensing a
tick top collab it's just amazing it's
there's so many opportunities that I
I've been given because of it
justin has been tick talking during
quarantine a lot with his wife hailey -
as for Charlie she's been quarantine
with her parents and sister Dixie in
Connecticut how are you guys doing with
everything that's going on I think we're
doing pretty good ét caught up with her
shortly after she was knighted the
reigning queen of tick tock today she
has over 57 million followers I mean
you're the most followed person right
now on tick tock how does that feel it
feels awesome but I think it's truly
about just being able to have the
platform that I got I mean it's crazy
but it's really crazy and she told us a
reality TV show just might be in their
future definitely something that would
be super fun there's people that kind of
see what goes on when we're not just
posting here class which I feel like no
one really gets to see but people are
always talking about how they think our
family dynamic it's pretty cool like
they love it when we go live for that
supersize I mean it's really whatever
helps like us showcase what we're really
like